I read your comments and I respond to
them even if it means watching my little
pony to render the considered opinion on
bronies but lots of you have been trying
to get me to say that Disney purchasing
Star Wars is a bad thing
you think the JJ Abrams the creator of
Lost rebooter of Star Trek director of
the next Star Wars is going to put now
series of the Jedi they have Sith Lord
singing Randy Newman songs well you're
all wrong man I hate it when nerds
complain about things before they even
begin unless we're talking about the
next Terminator movie out in 2015 which
is obviously going to suck I'll be back
so you think this is going to ruin Star
Wars well let's take a look at another
beloved universe that Disney through it
yeah the house of mouse acquired the
House of Ideas in the early days of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe before Iron
Man 2 even and most geeks seem pretty
happy with the superhero movies since
then now is Disney going to KFI Star
Wars well first let's be clear
Star Wars is for kids
it has poop jokes and chaste romances
and made-up swear words scruffy-looking
nerf-herder look all but one Star Wars
movie has been rated PG meanwhile all of
the Disney Marvel films and all of the
Pirates of the Caribbean films for that
matter have had violence and swearing
and risque humour that merited pg-13
ratings and can we all just submit this
now after the prequels Len Wiseman could
introduce a werewolf vs. vampire romance
plot to the Star Wars universe and it
would still feel like a step up JJ
Abrams and his crew should be banished
to Ceti alpha v for what they did to
Star Trek but the ways they've betrayed
Roddenberry's vision turning the talky
character-driven TV series into a
sensory overload of frantically paced
action effects would actually help Star
Wars movies look Abrams universe of
faith and spiritualism relies on magic
that only works if you believe in
yourself does that sound like Star Trek
no it's Star Wars or especially Disney
I don't believe it
that is why you fail
oh and you're worried that Disney will
be smart Star Wars movies with cheesy
silly musical numbers let me just say
one thing
yum num eat shop yoga and another thing
I'm quite cynic feci and another thing I
think you get my point
let me know in the comments if you
prefer Huttese funk jams or a wat
celebration chance me I'm more of a
Riker playing trombone kind of guy
myself disagree with me leave a comment
below I'll tell you why you're wrong
[Music]